♪ ♪
>> Sean: HERE WITH MORE
REACTION TO ALL THE NEWS OUT OF
SINGAPORE, WHERE FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP,
FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST, SEBASTIAN GORKA.
RETIRED CIA OFFICER, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR DANIEL HOFFMAN.
I WILL START WITH DR. GORKA.
I LISTEN TO THE PRESS AND YOU
WOULD LITERALLY THINK THEY DON'T
WANT ANY SUCCESS.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, I DON'T
THINK IT COULD HAVE BEEN A
BETTER ESPECIALLY THE LEAD UP TO
THIS WHICH MADE IT WORTHWHILE TO
TAKE A SHOT.
>> TAKE THE POLITICS OUT OF IT,
WHOEVER YOU VOTED FOR.
IT'S THE FACT.
DONALD TRUMP COULD NOT HAVE
ACHIEVED MORE THAN 24 HOURS, 25
HOURS HE WAS AWAKE.
WHAT MORE COULD HE HAVE
ACHIEVED?
AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE IS
SOLVING THE PROBLEMS OTHER
PEOPLE LEFT FOR HIM.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS ABOUT THE LAST 25 YEARS,
FROM BILL CLINTON ONWARDS, THE
SITUATION IN THIS PART OF THE
WORLD ON THE PENINSULA WAS
GETTING WORSE AND WORSE BY THE
YEAR.
THE NUCLEAR CAPABILITY,
DETONATING NUCLEAR WARHEADS,
LAUNCHING BALLISTIC MISSILES
OVER THE SEA OF JAPAN WITH A
RANGE OF MORE THAN 2,000 MILES.
THOSE ARE NOT PROBLEMS CREATED
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
BUT GUESS WAS TRYING TO SOLVE
IT?
IT'S JUST FACTS.
>> Sean: AS I SAID YESTERDAY,
YOU WERE SOMEONE WHO WANTED THE
PRESIDENT TO MANAGE
EXPECTATIONS.
DID HE EXCEED THEM?
>> I THINK HE HAS.
I ALSO THINK HE HAS EFFECTIVELY
MANAGED THE SUMMIT.
IT SPARKED A FLURRY OF
DIPLOMATIC ENGAGEMENT.
FOLLOW-UP MEETINGS, WE ARE
ALREADY SEEING SECRETARY
POMPEO'S ENGAGING IN SHUTTLE
DIPLOMACY.
IT >> Sean: NORTH KOREAN MEDIA
SAID THEY ARE COMING TO THE
STATES.
>> THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
MEETINGS IN PREPARATION FOR
THAT.
IT REINFORCES THE BAN OF TESTING
OF NUCLEAR MISSILES AND ICBMs.
I THINK THAT'S EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE FOLLOW-ON
AGREEMENTS, MAY BE IN PYONGYANG
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., SO WE CAN
SUPPORT THE ENGAGEMENT.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT SAID NO
DEAL UNLESS IT'S COMPLETE,
VERIFIABLE AND IRREVERSIBLE.
>> IN THE MEANTIME, WE HAVE
OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE ALSO BEING
RESOLVED OF OUR 7,000 MIAS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHICH ISSUE
YOU CHOOSE --
>> Sean: THAT'S AN ISSUE.
>> 7,000.
>> Sean: TRYING FOR YEARS.
THERE MIGHT'VE BEEN PEOPLE LEFT
BEHIND IN VIETNAM.